[Funny Music]
Narrator: As a mobile software developer,
Become familiar with the latest products and indicators
Is essential to running a successful business.
So we've created an application that lets you know
The secrets of success.
Using the Playbook app with Google Play
Discover features, best practices, and tips
To achieve greater success with your products.
Choose topics related to your app
And your turn to receive customized news and text messages.
Browse organized articles and videos
From Google and around software development.
You can quickly scroll through an article to take action with it.
Explore the road map
For Google software developer products.
Get the Playbook app from Google Play today.